hello YouTube I'm going to answer a
question about whether we're gonna get
growth and let me tell you the real
problem the problem is that the Grouse
were having was not real it was like a
uninsured risk-taking that gave the
illusion of growth with huge amount of
downside risks are we paying for now let
me give you an example take two
companies one company makes $2 a share
doesn't have insurance eventually it's
going to go bust that looks good on
paper another company makes $1 a share
but it's very robust it does not have
downside risk its insured against what I
call the Black Swan the first company
looks better according to economic
strict metrics according to economic
measurements but the second one in the
long run is the one that will survive so
that's not shoot for growth that shoots
for robustness let's work on a society
that is robust to model error robust to
the black swan the Society difference
from the one the banks gave us let's
smash it back away from thank you